Yo ! C'est Cyrus et bienvenue dans le Coup de Phil'.
Pour les deux prochains épisodes,
on va voir comment les anciens ont essayé d'atteindre ce but.
Ce but qui est le plus naturel...
...le plus instinctif et peut-être même le plus partagé chez tous les humains : être heureux.
Et pour ça on va commencer par une pensée qui est méconnue,
car l'image qu'on s'en fait est souvent en décalage par rapport à la réalité.
C'est l'épicurisme...
...d'Epicure.
Ce qui est logique en fait, parce que c'est épicurisme.
Epicure c'est un philosophe Grec
qui a donné son nom à une philosophie qu'il a enseigné notamment dans son jardin,
le jardin d'Epicure, et qu'il a développé dans la Lettre à Ménécée.
C'est une lettre dans laquelle, ses idéaux au contraire ne mourraient pas, mais naissaient...
Déjà il faut savoir que les Epicuriens sont des atomistes.
En gros, ils ont imaginés une pluie d'atomes qui tombent...
...sauf que bon, ils ne tombent pas droit, sinon ils ne se toucheraient jamais,
ils ont un petit angle de chute qui s'appelle Clinamen.
Et c'est grâce au Clinamen qu'il y a de l'indéterminisme et du hasard dans cet univers composé d'atomes.
Très malin.
Les mecs te sortent ça, alors qu'on est quand même au 4ème siècle avant J.C. quoi.
Genre, à titre de comparaison c'est bien avant Windows 98.
Bref du coup le monde est régit par des mécanismes atomiques.
C'est à dire qu'en fait tout ce qui nous arrive, ça vient des atomes,
hors à l'époque on pensait que tout ce qui nous arrivait ça venait des dieux et de leur volonté.
Du coup bah, y a plus aucune raison de craindre les dieux. Les dieux ils existent et ils font leur bail.
(sonneries)
(sonnerie)
Et c'est pareil pour la mort, faut pas la craindre...
...c'est juste les atomes qui s'organisent de manière différente, mais c'est un état normal.
Et en plus, tant que je suis, heu ben la mort n'est pas là
et une fois que la mort est là, ben c'est que je ne suis plus.
Donc en vrai on ne rencontre jamais vraiment la mort.
Vous ne trouvez pas que la mort, elle vient tout le temps au bon moment ?
Hors pour les Epicuriens, le principal obstacle du bonheur, c'est la peur.
La peur de la mort, donc ce qu'on à vu avec le divertissement Pascalien par exemple.
Et la peur des dieux, hors ça tombe bien, on vient de montrer qu'ils ne sont pas à craindre.
Donc on vient de lever les principaux obstacles du bonheur, du coup on va pouvoir aller le chercher...
...et pour ça on va faire ce que fait notre corps naturellement.
C'est-à-dire que notre corps naturellement, il suit le plaisir et il fuit la douleur.
Et bien on a cas faire pareil.
L'Epicurisme est un Hédonisme, c'est-à-dire une recherche des plaisirs et un évitement des souffrances ;
pour les Epicuriens c'est ça qui va nous mener au but recherché,
qui est l'Ataraxie.
L'absence de trouble.
En gros une paix intérieure quoi.
Et c'est avec cette recherche de plaisirs qu'il y a de gros contre-sens.
Y en a qui pensent que l'Epicurisme c'est une philosophie du kiff et de la décadence,
notamment à cause de ce "Carpe Diem".
- Faut que la recherche des plaisirs elle soit avant-tout...
...ah non en fait j'ai oublié ! Va-y YOLO les gars !
(choeurs) YOLO ! YOLO ! YOLO !
- Non parce que tous les plaisirs ne valent pas le coup...
...certains plaisirs ont des peines qui les surpassent.
Par exemple, t'es en soirée, tu te prends une cuite avec tes potes.
Sur le coup c'est cool, mais le lendemain souvent t'es grave dans le mal.
Et à l'inverse, t'as certaines peines qui valent le coup par rapport à ce qu'elles apportent derrière.
Par exemple, une grosse séance de sport,
bah sur le coup c'est difficile, ton corps ressent de la douleur,
mais après t'as un vrai bien être durable.
- Allez là on échauffe bien les talons, c'est important.
- Mais ça fait mal !
- Achille ça suffi maintenant hein.
Si tu continue on va finir par croire que t'es grec.
- Donc tout plaisir n'est pas à rechercher et toute douleur n'est pas à éviter.
Il y a un Calcul des Plaisirs.
Et c'est dans cette même logique, qu'il va proposer une classification des désirs.
Il y a trois types de désirs.
Les désirs naturels et nécessaires. Genre boire et manger simplement.
Les désirs naturels et non-nécessaires. C'est boire et manger mais de manière un peu plus sophistiquées.
Ok, mais avec modération.
Et les désirs non-naturels et non-nécessaires. C'est-à-dire la gloire et l'amour de l'argent.
Donc ça c'est à éviter car ils troublent ton âme.
En plus, vu que les choses auraient pu être différentes ; avec le Clinamen...
...et ben j'aurais pu ne pas exister.
Et le premier kiff, c'est quand même du coup d'apprécier pleinement mon existence.
De se dire putain, j'aurais pu ne pas être là quoi.
On peut noter aussi que c'est une philosophie ouverte à tous.
C'est à dire qu'il accueillait tout le monde dans son jardin.
Que tu sois pauvre, esclave, prostituée ou même les trois en même temps.
Alors que ce n'était pas le cas d'Aristote et Platon qui étaient avant lui.
J'espère que l'Epicurisme est maintenant plus clair pour vous.
N'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour ne rater aucune vidéo.
Moi je vous laisse, je vous envoie du love et de la peace. Yalah !